like a turkey you put your arms behind
you oh my god Adams okay baby okay
feeling okay okay I don't know James
right video game yeah hello and welcome
to other against play video games it's
been months since our GM's of luck here
but areas drive our tractor have you
been fella I've been driving this whole
time because the tractors really not
that fast taking me about two months to
get to where we are right now that's
good we are playing Ghost Recon
wildlands which is in a closed beetle
and applause theatre de Peter of it Jim
I say beta Rico Peter so here on a wild
one we are going to steal a car are you
can do it every time I say wild love
i'll add something about wild lands
which I really love is the use of drones
so by pressing up on the d-pad we can
bring out our are drawn and I've leveled
mine up not massively but it helps to do
with a little bit of tagging angle marks
but he's got a civilian you're buying
knife I'm intelligence with civilians in
here by there when women's moguls of
tangos and have come the ground okay can
I shoot him on in a head oh I can do
your own show I shake your drone use
iMovie head let's see if the bullet goes
fast quick and we're now buried go off a
bit did you kill house it hit the drone
instead you're in the West haha you read
the pretty white male 2 yeah I'll
finally go oh Jesus cool I stealth daddy
they're all coming a thing but
okay that one is wrong way jose
moratoria they realize that look so good
I mean gloomy neck I swear it died
already maybe you're older guys outside
of that building you go gay wrestling
reference Oh today's reston reference on
this then you can understand the summer
stand up stand up stand up stand up
stand up stand up late and of no sorry
I'm talking to that guy who will get an
edge that's why should I don't care
again Stand Up Stand Up Stand Up Stand
Up Stand Up Stand Up Stand Adam she's
really really big Spanish stand-up
comedy Oh Stan offer god no I'm getting
I'm gonna game don't worry stop it
laughing at you cloudland fire there's a
load that was tagged I didn't realize
I'm how I'm Bobby died oh no oh yes or
stealth we're pretty good at though I'm
not even sure if I have my suppressor on
Cloudland that cars going online oh yes
I've got night vision on mine have you
on your drove ya know ever in it in it
I'm Mike Rosario couple laughs it's not
entirely different oh yes the untagged
tags I'm gonna try and get I'm gonna get
em under them okay I'll get it on a
close look at Wow looking for you I'm
gonna celebrate like is trying to rum in
here with major on offense is in a way
are you just went through the bed John
them skill / land again we are now at
the end of Ghost Recon wildlands the the
debater anyway and we just were just
looking over the panorama that is
Bolivia so the right place I don't
believe you not much I guess and we are
at the final mission which is in this
little cut here but this Court has a
secret I'm too much Richard before we go
into quite like the light right there's
more stretching up almost ready I'm
almost ready clanking good add up and
down I'll to the thought of me and you
in here I'm cuddling you better not be a
woman right if going on I seat down
delfin i can i can talk [ __ ] so we try
and save any much your let him die oh
look it's that big girl ah oh it wasn't
like big girls you are beautiful what
happen time ago though copy these late
he stood on the shoulder you stood on
the chair oh my god that looks so cool
they were shooting them I think this
might prove this bit go go go like what
proper SWAT team cap from a grenade are
thrown it really badly move ah
I like really killed me right whoa she
took a few bullets hey still alive dude
only one way to check is to not go alive
are you doing X so let me do it are we
off down we are down down down like
people died on ok oh there I met chillin
it just say kill above his head let me
get over here hand combat oh yeah yeah
where are you what I just wrangled him
did you not see me to strangle clean up
and move on no you must lean invisible
come on up the next to no no you were
invisible right you're you're on that
good I'm well I'm not my god i'm stuck
on eyes it right you're actively moving
left and right with the gun well i am
i'm not even near I'm not now get rid of
it yeah I'm your arms Oh mr. awfully
final behind your shoulder you dislocate
your shoulder are those freaky was
happening spinner Alice disappeared I'm
stuck on a cable car never thought about
the whole like a turkey you're poking
around behind your back removing oh yeah
you are you in that's right good I'm
doing it right oh yeah okay dude well
bye
oh my god cloudland okay if I'm still on
the turret let's mess around with it I'm
gonna get in the helicopter hang on do
you want me to look at the turret then I
don't know come out as I see if they
only got to fly in itself really i'll
fly okay
whoa it's bright outside right I guess
on the map I could see the helot oh yeah
the helicopters just floating just the
propellers are not moving and there's no
one driving I mean it really is a ghost
helicopter hey cloud lands okay so this
was a demand Jim play video games we
attempted to play the wild one demo
Ghost Recon wildlands classes but it
ended up being a bit of a glitch with
you but James what do you think of it in
general it was a glitch fest but it was
a lot of fun if you've watched any other
one Jim Killeen videogame videos you'll
know if we like to a commit suicide at
the end of each video is actually
possible we've jumped off signs with a
in terms of hot air balloon we've shot
ourselves in the head we've pulled up
people's eyeballs in each video strong
but this time we're just going to
plummet to our death good night sweet
prince Oh Adam Jones Oh baby okay video
game video game I don't know James Oh
video game yeah